[Music]
hello everyone okay this is the last
session right after the session you may
go back to home what I may have a some
drink with my prayer nice to meet you my
name is Terry a customer here from the
cloud team it is the early honor to
introduce our respectable-looking
use-case Sam saw people I introduced our
customer I will briefly introduce
logging itself and stackdriver
okay let's start so what is logging
logging is catering event and the
information to see the state of the
system just appears ago we just used
logging for the troubleshooting and the
debugging and we collect the log into
the single PI and the majority by using
the tailing comment right but logging
can be used for the multiple purpose for
example for developer low can be used
for the debugging and code optimization
for the system engineer it can be used
for the health check and the system
monitoring protocol changing it can be
used to protect the system to find the
abnormal behavior and nowadays data
engine is being more important so the
data are complicated through the row to
find the inside from to find the inside
in this listen we need to collect more
logs from the Piraeus layer for example
we can collect the CPU and memory status
from the infrastructure and waist level
and we can get us web access law from
the web server or database also we can
collect a load from the usual
application this globe which can be used
for the multiple purpose like business
analytics auditing filling sums right
there because of the we need more footy
terminal okay until I until ow it may be
okay but the power
means system is being moved to the
distributed architecture like a
Microsoft right cause of that it may
have a lot of loci so with a single
motor we cannot monitor the horror blow
so what is the solution the solution is
we can use more and more more multiple
monitors right but actually it is
another technical solution so I will
introduce a technical solution to
monitor the distributed architecture
here is the general architecture of the
local system we can collect a log from
the system and the send it into the
message queue like a cop car and appear
in the message queue we can consume the
log the collected log will stored into
the lower storage system for the
archiving purpose and the log will be
indexed by using the index for the
social purpose so user can search he and
the buter law but the problem is as I
mentioned the law can be used for the
multiple purpose like data analytics or
the system notification and nowadays
machine learning is more being imported
so the log data log data can be
concerned by the machine learning system
to train the model right this system can
be implemented by yourself whether you
can implement this system by compositing
multiple open source but the problem is
it takes a long time to learn build
and you can also bring operation of
overawed so what is the solution
Google has a stack tribal structure IVA
is operation and the monitoring system
it combines logging monitoring debugging
trace etc if you didn't have a chance to
investigate structure of I strongly
recommend you to be get demo boost I saw
that there are a lot of state driver
demo it is the only real awesome tool in
addition so stock driver can learn over
the multiple cloud infrastructure
including the Google cloud and our
modern recipes
today I will just focus on the logging
on the in the state tribal or logging
you can suppose the logo collection post
it can collect a logo by using the SDK
or some agent the collected log will be
stored and it can be searched and the
butte in the poutine sector i will login
console and collected law can be laude
to the multiple destination state level
can be worked like a low growl router
for example it is very similar to the
cop kind open source from the logo pie
we can extract the metric for example we
can count the number of the error
whether we can extract the overall
response time of our service with de
pint is nightly we can also define the
notification for example if we have a
some number of an incident you can send
us a notification message to the system
operator by using the email or the SMS
or pager to change line and the last
thing is a local management for the
multiple project now this as I mentioned
the system architecture is being changed
to the distributed way
so the plication can be deployed into
the multiple cloud project in case of
Google and the multiple account in case
of Amazon if we have to monitor the all
over all in different project and the
different cloud console it may be very
very painful so the stack driver can
collect all up log into the single place
and you can monitor the all log in a
single player of plans
okay let T type each of log it's your
picture the first thing is how we
collect a log
the sector I will provide the SDK the
SDK can be easily integrated with the
well-known logging frame for example you
know in case of Java SL puja and the
logo bag is usually used this is such a
valid answer as you can see okay as you
can see you know there are no code
changes you just simply change the
maven dependencies
- injects a stick driver looking library
it is really easy but unfortunately
sometimes we need a collector load from
the beauty in solution like a database
or the web server or sometimes you're
looking Prairie mod cannot be supported
by the stock driver in the case we can
use the stick driver agent which is
based on the flow into the open source
agent so you can collect a load from the
PI by using this agent after you collect
a log you can easily search here and the
view the logo by using the spectral log
impute in concern is still the easier
and you can also support a coronary
directly so after Luke has been
collected as I mentioned for the
multiple purpose users it can be loaded
to the multiple destination like Google
Cloud through G it is photo log
archiving proposed and the pop so can be
used for the low streaming so the behind
the pop so you can put the real time in
our system were some transformation
system for the data formatting were you
can export a login to the bakery for the
data analytics you can export the law to
the multiple destination based on the
cue trainer so it means that you can
selectively export a load to the
multiple destination in addition
basically stick trouble logging pricing
is based on those stored alongside if
you have to throw a lot of low it can
bring a cost issue so the structure of
also property exclusion filter which
means that you can selectively store the
law based on the filter and you can save
the cost nowadays the logging has more
meaningful I mean that a few years ago
we just looking for the troubleshooting
so the text message was enough but the
developer tried konchem doesn't era like
a user ID and the transaction ID price
from the log in the case the structure
logging permit is more effective like
JSON from Edward CSV Pune
secretary will support our JSON
formatting but this is a note that is
example if we you write a log with a
simple net it is automatically mapped to
the JSON payload element in the
structure below entry and if we exported
this JSON log into the big query each
element in the JSON payload will be
mapped to the column in the pakora table
so it helps you to more sociable and a
little from the strode over we can
define the metric we already have a some
pretty panda metric which is called as a
system a tree we can get a data like a
byte count toward a number of logo entry
but if you want to collect a specific
information from the your log you can
define a custom log in two ways the
first way is the
contem a tree it is the simple contem a
tree but it you can define the sum
condition for example I want to collect
a number of laws that latency is over
than the 1.0 second and the other way is
distribution metric it occurs the
statistical distribution like a standard
deviation some averaging it can be used
for the for example you can collect the
average response time of the your
service and then is the exam how you
define the metric religion and with the
T symmetry you can visualize the metric
by using the Kraft through the state
tribal monitoring console it is one of
the example of the web response time and
this is a hit makrand you can get a some
insight about your system status
register after we define the metric we
can make us a loading system with
predefined the road sector evolve ascend
doesn't notification to the paralysis
destination from the emails
SMS and you can send a notification to
the your application through the pops up
q last one is a centralized logging as I
mentioned in Microsoft's architecture
ET service can be deployed to the tip on
the system and different project in
google and the deeper and Amazon account
so the collecting the log into the some
centralized system is very very
important so sector eyeball can collect
oral log into the one ccp project and
the can provide the single plane of the
glass for the long winter okay
until now we quickly look through the
logging system with a strict driver but
logging system can be extended for
pariahs purpose like a potato in our
case it is a way how we can extend the
logging system in the other world when
we try to use the load data for the big
data analytics actual there is be a
little tea I mean that it doesn't follow
the format and it doesn't follow the
tight sometimes and sometimes the fluid
is no so we need a data validation and
the transformation inspector over we can
export the logging into the topsail
behind the sectarian and the
commissioned by the data flow data flow
is open-source version of the Apache
which is very similar to the Apache
stock streaming and you can be used for
the PT tonalities
so you can put a some validation and the
transformation logic in the Google data
flow but unfortunately data flow is
require some coding by using the Java
and the Tizen it because a little bit
tiny
learning curve however instead of the
your manual coding stick driver provide
a template picture it means that you
don't need to code by clicking by a
number of clicking in the Google Cloud
console you can make all data ingestion
pipeline in addition if you need
as some transformation logic you can
simply implement it by using javascript
which is named the UDF user-defined
function so the user-defined function
can be unloaded to the TGS without any
packaging like cherry pie in the Java so
you just simply unload it and point it
out from the theta proconsul during the
dataflow run it will pull the
transformation logic and converts the
data format by using the tape
stackdriver login we can collect a log
from the server side but in big data
analytics world we wanted to collect all
of user journey from the advertisement
marketing mobile lab poetry Google
provided a solution for mobile firebase
varieties can gather to all of user
event information and ascended into the
picori and the pro web you know Google
energies can collect all of user event
from the website in addition the quarry
is served has a lot of data connector
you know we can collect the
advertisement network tailor Google Play
and YouTube data as I know the in this
week Google announced that Pico the
additional connector through the partner
so now we can collect over than 100 data
source across SNS advertisement and the
legacy system so all over data can be
stored in the pit corriander you can
analyze the user behavior from end to
end
it is really cool isn't it no thank you
ok the other problem in the microservice
architecture is correlation of the logo
LeConte the problem is let's say that
the usual a send the request to the user
service and they either write log into
local PI system and the you do send the
leakage to the other service like a
service item service usually also called
same thing but the problem is I want to
track
a sleek Estonian so how can we do
correlate the user service and the items
of its law the way is we can put some
correlation ID which is trace ID so when
usual calls the user service it will
automatically generate the trace ID and
the soil into the log together and the
user service and the record to the items
of it this tracer ID will be propagated
together and the right into the logo pad
so by using this trace ID you can
correlate the logo entry from between
the different services you can implement
it by yourself but fortunately there are
open source named seeking if you are
interested she can open source into your
login system it will automatically
create the trace ID and the propagator
ID to the other system and the trace ID
also will automatically return to the
Europan together
I'm sure the chicken is not a logging
system it is originally designed to
support the distributed system trace it
means that you can trace the latency in
history bill system by in trouble
provision by call the service usual
service and I item service but I don't
know where is the butler how long time
does it take spa DT service after utk
integration state terrible also support
the chicken by using stick driver trace
stick toy boat race will collect at
least Leighton's in Drayton's
information and the visualize by using
great like this one this is really good
but the problem is to use a cheap King
you need to inject your chicken suits
code to your application but I wanted to
collect the other system latency which
cannot be injected by the simple example
database web server but I want to check
the trace in the case we can resolve
this problem in the infrastructure area
instead of fixing the code we can put
some proxy in front of the service which
is my proxy it is very much a she and
she proxy but in the micro service world
we need to develop a lot of fraction in
front of each of service instead of that
is to use mainly service mainly the
amboy service it can automatically
indexed or m'boy in front of your
service so the livery the list of the
application program language you can
collect all of trace log and this trace
log can be integrated with the state
driver service monitoring as you can see
you know that in the Microsoft circuits
the topology and the service dependency
is really really complicated but it
shows the topology like this one and it
also provides the important information
like all response time I raise sheep
utilisation that's right okay final
thing is of personal information
personal information is very very
sensitive right if we - it will store
the personal information to the store it
is originally designed for the personal
information handling email a type of
trouble but sometimes unexpectedly the
PII while user information can be stored
in your logging system it is critical to
prevent that we can use the DLP API data
loss prevention which is based on the
Google motional in technology it can
automatically detect the user
information like social security number
or some other information and you can
anonymize what has she make it as a hash
table
hash value so the you can prevent the
personal information to be stored in the
logging system okay from last year by
using the stackdriver logging Sansa
started to move to the innovation to a
sari and the Devas Fort Davis Devas
practice so today I we
introduced head over Samsung mobile
operation system synonym to stage is you
thank you all right it's great to be
here
it's honored to be actually present on
my presentation you know Google next
coming to this large of tech conference
for me is really a treat for me and I
remember my first big conference was
about nine years ago and I was
infrastructure engineers of this
engineer with the big software company
and at the time this was about the cloud
conference and I was really it was
really eye-opening for me because as a
infrastructure engineers whenever an
engineering team asked me to deploy
provision news over in the traditional
data center it takes about three months
it's I think like its industry standard
whenever you try to deploy news over in
a traditional data center it takes about
three months but then you know in a disc
conference they tell me I can
provisioning you know number of servers
in a ten minute less than ten minutes
right and it was like you know this is
what where I need to be right with my
courier I want to be in a cloud and I'm
trying to do more of work you know makes
my life easier and helping our
engineering team as well I that sort of
feeling I had with the Google next this
year as well I when I hear about Antos
you know it was like you know new war
from you as well because I've been
trying to move over some of our legacy
system into a container lies it and be
more efficient more flexible and you
know it was really hard to get a you
know a lot of time from our engineering
team asking code changes right
but in this end hose were able to do
that without code changes and it's free
right so it's really great to have those
kind of future coming to industry as
well but uh let me
okay so uh have you guys heard company
names
Samsung Electronics right okay good I'm
pretty sure you guys know about Samsung
electronic we create or bill pre awesome
consumer electronics including handset
devices right very you know innovative
and you know we have a list of business
inside of Samsung Electronics but then a
Samsung back in Korea
Samsung it's not only about you know
consumer electronic manufacturer we are
in business of construction insurance
and theme park hotel and you know many
more of a business really Nana's in
Korea so it's they Sarah it's easier to
list out the business that Samsung is
not in compared to you know we are in
this huge technical a technology company
is has a tremendous value in the their
name and for the most of the college
graduate it is dream job to come in into
a Samsung and work for the company
because one of the reason is you know
good pay of course and you know provides
job security the reason is that such we
have such a big Pro folio of you know
business sector that if there's a
downturn in on one business we can ship
those people we don't have to lay people
off what that mean is we ship those you
know some of those people moving into
another business sector so you know with
your Samsung with the big company you
have a pretty good level of a job
security as well and support or some of
the folks it'll be great
opportunity to work in a global
environment you get to talk to a lot of
a global smart people and you know try
to learn your way in a career trying to
understand from the global environment
so that's another advantage you know
those college kids wants to have as well
but then I'm pretty sure it was only
reason that Samsung is also starting to
be known as a service company so I have
a list of this application service that
we are running trying to add more value
to our
smartphone devices for example Samsung
pay is you know for in my opinion most
innovative service that we ever created
in a samsung electronic providing
digital eyes a credit card or a bank
card into your phone and you can
virtually pay using this phone you can
pay anywhere that you want to pay
including you know if this point-of-sale
device only accept the MST which is a
maganet Ogoni you can still use some
some pay devices and some some pay
services to pay with it
it's huge success in the Korea and some
other of the country as well we have a
Samsung Account where Samsung past which
is a biometric authentication mechanism
where you know as long as you have a
thumb and you know what first you know
when you act trying to access an you
know network resource with your login
information and password after that
information safely into the phone you
don't have to memorize that anymore
right so that informations securely safe
into your devices all you need is a
thumbprint to access any of your network
resources and we are also in a b2b
business and we provide ad like activity
tree like you know solution for Android
devices trying to work with the our
partner in the different business sector
let's I'm gonna show you a little bit
more about the samsung AI system call or
Bixby say hi to the new Bigsby Samsung's
intelligent assistant
hi big speech what's all my schedule
this afternoon you have one event
scheduled today at 1 o'clock p.m.
meeting with pattern maker change this
event on to 2 p.m.
I'll set I save the events
[Music]
hi pixy fine italian restaurants nearby
here are some italian restaurants nearby
give me a table for three today at
Luciano's at 1 p.m. you're all set for
lunch
[Music]
vixie give me an over to work the fair
for this ride will be twenty one dollars
and 72 cents ready to request right
perfect
[Music]
Isaac speaks its runtime okay
turning on Bluetooth starting a run in
samsung health clean run playlist
[Music]
alright that's about the fix P today
about 57 millions registered users are
utilizing bixby services and with the
latest version of the big city service
we are supporting a Korean English and
Chinese and only this year we added five
more languages that most of European
uses it today and this year next year
we're going to keep on expanding
supporting different languages on the
global and now with 2.0 changes that we
made with the big huge change is we are
trying to open up our AI system to our
partners we provide the same tool
machine learning tools that we are using
in our internal and we're providing out
to our partner to utilize that as well
and not only popular is partner as long
as you are developer and as long as you
know how to use our tool you should be
able to integrate with the depicts be
sort of like you know a player Play
Store that you can upload your app into
a place or you can do the similar thing
with the Bigsby the Bachmann portals so
to find out mobile from the exhibit
department portal if you wanna reach 57
million or users before your business
and including is not only the handset
device you will be TV and refrigerator
any you know consumer electronic device
can connect to our network we will you
know integrate with your picks be in the
future you know next my colleague Joe
Gyung will be explaining about the what
what are the challenges we've been
having managing big CB you know big size
of lock with the 50-plus size of micro
services we are learning today and then
how stackdriver help us to addressing
some of those problem
hello everyone my name is giorgia and
i'm the devops member in HP project it's
really honored to present my experience
here I hope that our small the
experience can give you that they could
the opportunity to understand how we are
overcome that situation about the
logging and it will be a good technical
reference for you yeah let's get into
the background actually we have the the
new of Pixma services now and previous
it means that previously we have another
a big service usually when we call about
the logging system the logging system is
usually for the debugging and the
monitoring and also the analysis purpose
too but with the small size of the
project or the services can consider
that maybe just to use the e lk for the
logging system or some kind of this open
source of solutions to overcome the
situation however the some services that
is for customer service or the large
scale services always use try to build
their own logging system that is for the
reliability and scalability - and
currently the pics be new pics be the
log data is almost a 1.5 terabyte per
day and we have to think about that how
much how we can satisfy that at the
real-time monitoring with using that our
current internal logging system and also
we have to do guarantee that the
reliability and scalability - for the
customer services so when we think about
the previous day log previous logging
system in XP services
the major key point was that logging for
debugging and the other one is
the cost saving point actually the
previous internal logging system was
developed by ourselves and that that
means that that is not as you are the
known solutions in their market it was a
designed in our side and developed in
the our development team and that is a
deploy to the or the clouds cloud
infrastructure and mostly all
requirement was as driven by the our
internal users so it is more easy to
satisfy the old requirement when we
develop ourselves for the logging system
however when we want to add new features
like the tracing or equally testing then
we have to change every infrastructure
under the design concept of the logging
system but that system was not designed
at that time and simply they log that
all log messages into a logging system
and simple monitoring was only supported
by the graph on ax so we have some
challenges how we can provide that the
tracing and mechanisms to the developers
to give some the health how they can
debug their issues when some issues are
detected in their own applications and
indeed when we are adding the new
logging system into our cloud
infrastructure and that goes the more
complex that complex complexity of the
system goes much higher than we expected
and it is not easy to adding new
features to the newer logging system as
well as the cost is also cause of high
and that the cost was the one of the big
challenges for us to reduce the infra
costing fee so that is the major ly
truly quest for the dab of scheme site
and we have to change or we have to find
out any solutions available in the
market
so we get a some suggestion from the
other team and that was not the from the
Google actually we searched that the
Aztec driver in the Google at the web
site and we found that we have to check
that what is our key feature for
providing that a new logging system so
firstly we have to think about the
real-time monitoring stack drivers
default that real-time monitoring is
based on the log based on metrics so as
well as the login system as using this
truck driver
it also can support it the real-time
monitoring but it is also is provided
easy ways to integrate with the other
monitoring solutions we in the pics be
one at all we have another the internal
monitoring solution and that is also
helped to be continuous continuously to
use for our operations so we have to
check that whether this tech driver can
support that the third party integrated
party monitoring solution integration
and we can guarantee that that is
impossible and the second the most of
the important thing was was the on the
login system is the experience of
debugging so now a free vyas login
system when the developers want to
search the any logs only the application
driven logs can be searched at the time
the one problem was all the developers
cannot make the standard log format at a
time and huge number of developers in
samsung was involved in this Bixby
development and they made their own
style to remain love messages it doesn't
show any related love messages for
debugging purpose so it means that
developers want to check that whether
his new detected issue is belongs to
tear for problem or
to another another another modules
problem we have to provide any tracing
mechanisms to developers to eat for a
provider providing the easy ways to
search the the love messages for
debugging so when we check that this
tech driver
it also can support that the tracing
mechanisms as using the automated trace
however it cannot be applied to our
internal the requirement actually if we
want to add that the auto created the
tracing ID we have to appreciate all the
developers to apply that requirement
through the pair source code it is not
easy
I think the as some of you are the work
in their big company the big company
have the several the organizations and
even though that organization is only
belongs to the development development
team have their own strategy and the
policies it is not easy to adding the
new code for only the tracing did the
tracing purpose into their code because
they just worry that any side effect and
any the performance degradation due to
the adding the new the mechanisms to
their own code so we have to make sure
that tracing is also need to be adding
the news the logging system and the we
made a new standard love format to apply
that the stack driver and secondly
previous logging system also provides
that the analytics of the system it
means that some of the log messages
should be gathered and that is sent to
the another analytics platform and that
platform is gathering all data and
providing that analysis data we have to
make sure that the stack driver have to
support that and we had a check that
whether that is available so after
checking that all requirement we can go
with the stack driver without any
building the internal logging system
internal logging system usually require
too much report to develop and also we
cannot satisfy that all the
project milestone to go forward so now
we could do that we have to do that
about that the love form and
standardization to to satisfy that the
tracing purpose the other one is that
usually when we built a new logging
system always we have to think about the
user management so when we use this tech
driver all the user the authentications
or user management is under covered by
the I am policy and the stack driver
loves logo pure is basically supported
so that every users who are cats and
career are the permissions to access the
log of Europe pages then they can
immediately search that the log messages
from the console excessive by the access
in the console and mostly important
thing is that some of the the whole the
infra related system metrics is
automatically that they created by the
stack driver agent and it is sending to
the sect driver services but we also
need to other another the custom metrics
to for from which is generated from the
application side so detect one of the
big child or big things about the stack
driver is that they can support at local
based metrics and they even if we can
communicate with the other application
developers and we can define that any
metrics in two metrics in that log
messages then it can gather it by the
filtered the log base in metric and it
is the one of the materials for the
operation and monitoring so now we have
the simple diagram so all those which is
a stored in the each modules is like
gathering by the servers and it by from
the spec driver logging agent do that
all the data is gathering and the
transfer that data to these the stack
driver service and then we can integrate
with the data one of the our major or
the monitoring solution
and that is gathering there all the love
based metrics and it can show that the
one unified format of the dashboard
it is the currently we are not going to
the a solid practice yet so we have the
transitional operation practices now so
that every tier 1 and tier 2 and even
the order 3 is using that to get us some
the any issue detection by the our own
dashboard also we also use data stack
driver monitoring tool to because the
that dashboard also providing that any
custom the dashboard creation and that
is also related with can be integrated
with the other solution like the open
source graph Anna and we have used this
latch channel to notify every warning or
the the complication for convenience and
and if we can define that any some alert
india's stackdriver and the data row
then it can automatically send that the
sec drive as select channel and then it
can goes to the stakeholders to
investigate any issue or for notified at
any operation process basically the
debugging is also can be available when
we access to the log viewer and for
analyst analytics purpose we are
gathering that all the log messages and
the filter them into the cloud storage
google cloud storage services and it is
going to the analytic system by pops up
so finally we can say that after
applying that the stack driver for
logging system we can have enough for a
number of the effectiveness after using
data stack driver
firstly we can talk about the cost
saving we can say that more at least
three times lower than a cost saving is
possible when we open when we use this
deck driver so it means that we don't
need to think about any in
changes or the maintaining maintaining
the system only that we can give the any
and all Apple to service reliability and
scalability and it means that secondly
we can the minimize that are all the
workload so we don't need to think about
any maintenance about logging system we
can fully give the energy to service
reliability 3 we when we use this deck
driver we also realize that unified at
this logging system can be applied to
another project if we the data
requirement is really similar with the
Bixby project so that our in our
operation team has much number of the
services as which in mentioned so that
if it is possible we can add in that the
stick driver to the other services as
the using the as the unified platform of
the logging system finally we also even
though we integrated with the analysis
Texas system internally in Samsung but
more better scalability and the another
purpose of the data analysis is also it
possible when we use in the bigquery so
this is my the last the pages so I will
back to dear Jean thank you
[Applause]
all right I know this is the last
session and I know you are eager to go
back to your you know home and so on but
I will make it quickly as possible but
this is my talk that I wanted to do
practicing s re trying to make that
happen in our environment as well so so
some of challenges as in Samsung's life
training we had I joined the company in
2013 I came from the large software
company in base in Redmond Washington
spent about 10 12 years there and I got
hired by Samsung and move my family to a
Korea and back then there's some other
guys like me who came from a you know
global esoteric software company and
then Samsung wanted to make an
environment where the software
department management is kind of normal
to our company because the company is
not came from yourself their base and
core business their core business is
manufactured right so are they trying to
create an environment try to create the
you know culture of a software
development but then you know as company
put more investment on a software
development we create more surface has
go on as every time we add more service
obviously there are more people to
operate those services as well so as you
know so but more being more add/edit to
the production environment we need more
people to operate and support those
services the problem is we feel that
we're not gonna able to justify ourself
of growing rate of operation team any
longer so we need to think about new way
of operation still able to support a
number of services coming into a
production as I being with the Samsung I
kinda lucky enough to witness all the
changes being done in the software
management inside of Samsung as well
as you can see you know pops product
right so we ship we release a flagship
devices every six months like we have a
series we have note series it takes
about six months waterfall methodology
off with development lifecycle kind of
make sense and box product you know
manufacture or system and we have all
the important decision is being made by
executives and since we have enough time
of lifecycle of these products and you
know obviously back then we have Yuri
utilize a lot of traditional data
centers who host our servers and all the
system is sort of like a monolithic
architecture system but then over the
year we know we can you know do this
type of many most management anymore
with the service development so we
change ourselves to a shelf coming from
the waterfall where you know we break
down all the tasks we're going to create
a backlog and we're trying to fulfill
back I'm going to give him the right
engineer to actually responsible for
those backlog and we run every spring
and trying to ship out at the end of the
shippable product to a production and
all the decision is now made being made
by a Pio or you know every key feature
in production whether it needs to be
going live or not being decide by our
product owner and obviously some of our
right now majority of our server are
being hosted in a cloud unless there are
compliance that to a server has to be
you know a traditional data center and
you know why going with the oddest
pattern of the making break down each
feature in the production it makes sense
to architect ourselves as a micro
services instead of the monolithic still
in an old way of the department life
cycle it as I mentioned we have six
months of time on waterfall and we have
we could have all the time every time we
have new service coming in we can
as an operation we can you know find
ourselves to ask engineer team create an
operation guide kb article and do the
right training what's coming into a
production environment and it all makes
sense but then in a with the project
managed by a gel and sprint we don't
have that luxury anymore we don't have
time to ask them or engineering
engineering team does not have a time to
provide all those information so we also
have a conflict between business and the
engineer and operation where our primary
is providing in a stable service to our
customer where engineering team trying
to push new value to a production
environment environment so we
continuously having this conflict while
we trying to solve this operation
conflict and organizational challenge we
were came close to chance to work with
the Google engineer Google srid
engineers and trying to learn more about
SRA practice in in what how Google does
their as our I practice in their in and
we went through a lot of meetings and
seminar with the Google engineers but
then we realized that Samsung is not
Google so what I mean is there we'd not
we didn't came from you know software
development company we came from the
very you know process driven manufacture
culture in our back of our mind so next
thing that we did was okay so we
understand what sre can give us what
kind of benefit but then we need to
answer how question how can we implement
this practice to our environment so we
start learning from other industry
leader in practicing as already we
learned from the Netflix LinkedIn Hoover
and many others and they all have
something in common too right so they
break down to each kind of you know
separate their what's putting into a
production and separate the wolf who is
should be responsible for addressing
those issue they have a notion of you
built it you run it so if there's a
table
who tried to push into a production and
that person supposed to be know how to
troubleshoot those issue not operation
engineers so we really like those notion
of the movement there as well
so we came out with our own version of a
sorry we we call it ourselves as a
global service real our engineer and we
break down to a different area of
implementation what so so before
pretty much every service that we are
running today does have SLA we do have a
key index of availability but then
that's not enough for SRA practice we
want to make sure we kind of break down
to each function within their service
and making sure each function does user
impacting function does have a SLO SLI
and also we want to make sure the error
budget is being communicated with the
engineering team so if you exhaust all
your SLO there we will focus on you know
making the reliable system instead of
pushing new idea into a production these
are the one of example above SLO
document we have as I mentioned you know
big sub is like such as a big CP have a
different functionality capability
within the service one of capability is
a chart which translate the alterans to
text so we create this template where we
break and break it down to an
application level as a ownership of that
as a low is primary ownership of SLO is
depth we have underneath primary
ownership of operation which is us
managing infrastructure libero SLO and
one of the key point is infrastructure
SLO is much tighter higher than
application as a law obviously in
application SLO could not be made if the
underlying you know framework is not
there yet right so that's why we're
trying to kind of differentiate between
operation primary responsibility and
engineering primary responsibility with
the help with the stack driver and data
we were able to create the
- bored just for that SLA so based on
this SLA if there's a SL a SL or
threatening event it is happening we can
integrate with your data dog and slack
and some other alerting mechanism we can
give the order to write engineers and
also that comes into a incident
management as well in before we take
traditional multi tier escalation path
rights we have a Tier one tier two tier
three which is you know essentially
developers if you should happen to one
can set and escalate the tio2 if they
don't have enough information to how to
troubleshoot and here to in operation
side supposed to know you know most you
know how feature is running in a
production in the production environment
but if you know name of the agile and
the service you know as I mentioned
there's always lack of information
what's are running in a production in
application level so we ended up you
know calling developer or pretty much
every time so if you think about SL all
of three nine five for our bill ability
you have only twenty two minutes of
allowed a downtime so in the middle of
night one of the incident happening like
this it's easier it's easy to you lose
about thirty minutes so for that month
if we have a single instant you're
violating it alone so you know we needed
to take the different approaches in sree
right so we try to pinpoint the actual
error and do a better job in on logging
we may not have to go through that here
1 and Q 2 if system generate the right
information and go push into the push
those all out to a right engineer it
could be a developer because it's about
you know even to is trying to violate
the SLO for application you could go to
infrastructure engineers if is violating
some SLO that will prevail for a network
rights for example so we can pinpoint
the a a lot and we can finish up the
doing you know the pipettes that it
wanted here escalation there
because I need to finish up with a quick
deploy management we you know same idea
we operation team used to own deployment
of products and environment we call
ourselves as as a production engineer
right so we have ownership of making
stable and color is therefore business
looking and customers looking but then
as we separately have with the SLO for
developer and operation engineer now we
are making the infrastructure as a code
configuration as a code operation have
ownership of pushing new changes if is a
configuration and infrastructure diverse
development team have ownership of
pushing new code into a production in a
that way you know we don't have to stop
development to deploy new code into
products and asking for bunch of kb
article to how to troubleshoot thing
because this is all loading when they
push a new idea and there's if there's a
problem the older team will go straight
to a developer not to operation who has
nothing knows nothing about those change
in the code cultural changes the last
thing but it's not listing this is the
hardest thing to do right so we kind of
communicate this to our leadership and
they all get the idea and you know first
comment was the of cultural innovation
you need to talk to make sure all
peoples in consents right so we starting
to do a lot of ground back seminar with
the different engineering team making
pushing this idea and make sure they're
on board and you know we ask for what we
it needs to be happen and you know what
help we're gonna be needing from them as
well and some other thing that we did
was we create a task force right so we
create a task force or dedicated team to
create your toolset right if we don't do
a tion deployment we provide the
pipeline the icd pipeline that a gradual
change is embedded into a pipeline risk
management is embedded as a pipeline
that you know it's no brainer for a
development team that
if they've trying to push a new idea but
if it's starting to having problem it's
easier for them to rollback as well so
we've trying to create a team providing
this type of a tool to engineering team
as well so say that same goes to with
the logging and monitoring and a QA
automation we don't have the QA
automation security automation yet we
have this multi plan organizational
change and trying to fit into this model
of sree and while we've prompt trying to
provide all cross your same tool set for
our sree we also have a service SLA who
are actually working on the project
trying to plug in those platform
solution into actual services as well I
can't really say all the benefit we are
having right now because we are still
only stage on the adapting asari but
then you know we are kind of expecting
to have a page of matter of visibility
of our service with the measuring
everything that what's happening in a
production and reducing the mean time to
recover
obviously right so I'm trying to meet
aslo and reduce the release time with
your CI see the pipeline automation and
optimize operation resource as well so I
think this is my last session thank you
for joining us and you may go to your
family now
[Music]